[Música]
siete personas fueron arrestadas en
relación con la exposición
a insultos racistas de las que fue
víctima el jugador vinicioso Junior
desde el Real Madrid del domingo pasado
sobre este caso hemos querido
profundizar en France 24 y en directo
América para entender lo que hay detrás
de estas denuncias de racismo en la liga
española que el mismo jugador dijo se
han normalizado vamos al análisis de
este tema y para ello nos acompaña
Esteban Ibarra él es el presidente del
movimiento contra la intolerancia
Esteban bienvenido directo a América
estamos también con uno de nuestro
editor deportivo Juan pupiales Juan
saludo para usted qué tal y esperemos
tener una conversación muy productiva
Esteban para empezar España es racista o
el deporte es racista
España no es racista y hay que ser
precisos no podemos generalizar a un
país con 48 millones y además está
reconocido en la Unión Europea
junto con Portugal e Irlanda como los
países de mayor tolerancia y aceptación
de la diversidad no pero hay
comportamientos racistas graves y hay
conductas racistas graves nosotros
venimos luchando contra todo esto desde
hace más de 30 años y el fútbol le pasa
lo mismo no podemos generalizar hay
comportamientos racistas dentro del
fútbol y además están protagonizados por
grupos ultras que hacen del racismo su
bandera y ahí es donde está el grave
problema porque las autoridades no están
acometiendo la erradicación de estos
grupos en los estadios
Esteban parece que con ese tema se tocó
una vela muy sensible en España España
es un país que de cara al exterior se
muestra como muy progresista frente a
este caso de vinicius hemos visto Voces
del gobierno central del gobierno
regional a recalcar no hay racismo en
España estamos combatiendo el racismo
parece que es como que sobre todo por lo
por las declaraciones que han venido por
parte de Brasil Que España se ha sentido
muy atacada cuando se dice que en el
país hay racismo
lo que no se puede es generalizar a todo
el país y ni se puede generalizar al
fútbol eh pero claro que hay racismo si
nosotros presentamos casi 200 denuncias
al año y esta denuncia de vinicius la
primera organización que la presentó fue
fuimos nosotros junto con la asociación
de futbolistas españoles y yo denuncié
el caso anterior de Wanda y el muñeco
que simbolizaba esa imagen del Claro que
hay y nuestra organización es fruto
después de un crimen horrendo el
asesinato de una mujer por ser negra por
ser inmigrante en 1992 O sea que sí lo
hay si hay conducta lo que nos negamos
es a que se generalice y otra cuestión
es que las instituciones no están
cumpliendo lo que deben no acometen una
estrategia adecuada tenemos leyes
tenemos una ley contra el ra tenemos un
código penal que sanciona este tipo de
conducta racistas pero hay que aplicarla
si se aplica débilmente pues entonces el
problema continúa y nos encontramos con
este tipo de episodios que no es único
es que lleva mucho tiempo y con otros
jugadores también sucediendo Bueno pues
podemos estar de acuerdo en que lo que
sucede con vicios Junior es que da más
visibilidad y sobre ese tema justamente
hay una nueva controversia porque el
comité de la liga le retiró la sanción
que le había impuesto inicialmente la
tarjeta roja en el partido contra el
Valencia pero el entrenador del
Barcelona Xavi Hernández dijo que no
debería mezclarse el partido como tal
con las ofensas que recibió vinicios
Usted qué opina
bueno son dos cosas distintas es decir
el ámbito deportivo el comité de
competición ha hecho esa valoración yo
creo que que tiene sus razones y además
hay juristas ahí que
en fin que tienen aportan una reflexión
como la teoría del árbol envenenado
porque claro solo se presentó la parte
final de El manotazo de vinicios a un
jugador pero es que antes a él le habían
agarrado del cuello en fin a lo mejor
había que haberlos expulsado a todos
pero si solo se le expulsa a uno pues
tampoco es correcto pero eso es una cosa
y el racismo es otra Es decir Vinicio
fue víctima de una acción organizada
racista nosotros lo decimos claramente
le insultaron nada más bajarse del
autobús le insultaron en el en la cancha
de fútbol y le insultaron cuando retornó
al autobús eso fue una acción organizada
quién la organizó Pues los grupos ultras
que además allí en Valencia tienen
[Música]
separarlo el comité de competición tiene
su tesis que lo resuelva pero lo otro lo
otro no lo otro hay dos organismos que
tienen que responder uno es la Comisión
Estatal contra la violencia y el racismo
que es una ley administrativa una un
organismo administrativo que tiene que
aplicar la ley administrativa y otro es
el código penal y la fiscalía de delitos
de odio que hasta ahora nos había
archivado todas las denuncias bueno
Esperemos que esta denuncia que hemos
presentado que luego ha presentado el
Real Madrid pues no la archive y
prospere porque entonces los que
detengan que tienen que ser muchos más
de los que han detenido los que detengan
tendrán que
sufrir la presencia en un tribunal y
haber las condenas que les pueden caer
Esteban en la liga tiene registrada en
lo que va de temporada 8 denuncias de
ataques solamente contra vinicios eso es
algo reiterativo volviendo al tema de
las sanciones que usted ya comentaba
antes es incapacidad o falta de voluntad
a la hora de querer sancionar y sentar
un precedente como parece que si está
ocurriendo ahora
bueno Nosotros hemos calificado todo
esto de indolencia institucional es
decir dejar hacer hay una banalización y
hasta ahora yo creo que la mirada
dominante era que eso se resuelva en el
ámbito del fútbol y no es así no es así
en primer lugar la gente tiene que tener
claro que el derecho al insulto no
existe Y si el insulto es un insulto
racista esto es un delito según nuestro
Código Penal está sancionado en un
insulto racista está sancionado con seis
meses de seis meses a dos años de cárcel
con lo cual no es una cosa que se pueda
resolver en el ámbito deportivo y en el
ámbito deportivo Tenemos también
sanciones importantes por ejemplo se
adopta como sanción el cierre de la
grada de Donde salieron los los insultos
en esa grada es donde están
fundamentalmente estos grupos ultras que
son racistas y como en otros estadios Eh
hay otros estadios donde También tienen
sus grupos ultras y su grupo racistas
por eso
u otros jugadores negros van a lo mejor
a Valladolid a Barcelona a otras
ciudades y se encuentran con otro tipo
de grupos de la misma naturaleza que
siguen insultándole porque recurren al
insulto para desmoralizar para dañar al
jugador al equipo etcétera entonces se
tiene que aplicar la ley administrativa
y esta vez han puesto una multa de
45.000 euros al club y han puesto un
cierre de cinco jornadas de cinco
partidos de esa grada donde salen los
insultos a mi juicio hay más que
sancionar Pero bueno de momento se
sanciona porque hasta ahora se había
estado en una situación de mucha
permisividad
Pues mira Esteban ya nos quedamos sin
tiempo Yo le agradezco por poner aquí en
la mesa su punto de vista Solamente le
agregaría que además de estos grupos que
ustedes denuncian como radicales Pues
estamos todos los espectadores
observando sin tomar acción al respecto
es este Manny barra presidente del
movimiento contra la intolerancia como
nuevo Le dije gracias a usted Gracias
Juan también y vamos a continuar con
directo América ya regresamos con
ustedes sigan con nosotros